la sanction est tombée le gouvernement
britannique gèle les avoirs de romane
abramovitch l'oligarque russe
propriétaire du club de football de
chelsea est la vente du club londonien
est donc suspendu pour en parler notre
chroniqueur sport cédric ferreira nous a
rejoint bonjour cédric merci d'être avec
nous que va-t-il se passer maintenant
pour le club anglais de chelsea a réagi
en communiquant sur le fait d'ouvrir des
discussions avec le gouvernement
britannique pour changer la licence
accordée au club pour je cite
fonctionner aussi normalement que
possible car le problème maintenant pour
chelsea c'est que ce club appartient
romane abramovitch depuis 2003 mais
l'oligarque fait désormais partie de la
liste des personnalités dont les avoirs
sont gelés au royaume uni abramovitch
avait d'ailleurs anticipé ce problème en
voulant vendre son club la semaine
dernière c'est désormais trop tard car
officiellement il n'a plus la main sur
le champion d'europe en titre qui passe
sous le contrôle du gouvernement
britannique l'homme d'affaires de 55 ans
n'a plus la possibilité d'effectuer des
transactions au royaume uni il ne peut
plus entrer non plus ni sortir du
territoire alors c'est vrai aussi que
ces derniers temps il passait beaucoup
de temps à l'étranger puisqu'ils
possèdent aussi un passeport israélien
et portugais le portugal qui a
d'ailleurs aussi annoncé il ya quelques
temps vouloir aussi ouvrir une enquête
sur les conditions de sa naturalisation
que ce grâce à ce passeport portugais
abramovich était aussi citoyens de
l'union européenne qu'est-ce que il va
se passer maintenant ce qui est clair
c'est que roman abramovich à pcc liens
très étroits avec le kremlin et en
particulier avec vladimir poutine et oui
puisque comme tous les oligarques russes
au royaume uni vladimir poutine et roman
abramovich était assez proche il fait
partie de tous ces oligarques russes qui
ait su rester proche du kremlin tout en
restant aussi à l'écart de la politique
et pour se justifier d'ailleurs le
gouvernement britannique indique que
robben abramovitch est impliqué dans la
déstabilisation de l'ukraine et dans
l'atteinte de sa souveraineté car
actuellement pour lui un robin
abramovitch il ya chelsea bien sûr mais
il ya aussi ces affaires par exemple il
est le principal actionnaire du
sidérurgiste russe et brazil détient
aussi des parts dans la société russe
norilsk nickel spécialisée dans
l'exploitation du nickel et du palladium
et puis pour rappeler un peu le contexte
un roman abramovitch c'est quelqu'un qui
est devenu un homme d'affaires très
puissant après la chute de l'union
soviétique en 1991
il a fait des affaires dans des secteurs
variés comme le pétrole l'aluminium
l'automobile et c'était en 2002 en 2003
qu'il a décidé de diversifier ses
investissements en investissant dans le
football à chelsea car c'est un
passionné de sport également mais il
avait senti le vent tourner avec toutes
ces sanctions qui s'abattent sur les
oligarques russes il avait essayé de
sauver les meubles comme on dit comme
l'expression le permet puisque la
semaine dernière il avait passé la
gestion de chelsea à la fondation
caritative il avait aussi promis que la
vente du club se le produit net seraient
versés à une fondation caritative au
profit de toutes les victimes de la
guerre en ukraine voilà ces gestes de
bonne volonté n'ont pas suffi pour lui
éviter des sanctions et maintenant il
est bien il fait partie aussi de ces
oligarques russes qui n'ont plus la main
sur leur salle la rassure vos avoirs au
royaume uni est la vente donc du club
londonien chelsea est suspendu merci
beaucoup pour tout c